alright so the mandalorian episode 2 was
gonna come out with three days after
episode 1 didn't expect that so less
than a day after I talked about episode
1 I now get to talk about episode 2
probably could have binge them both in
the a.m. at least two episodes which
would have been better because I feel
like this is actually part of episode 1
that they were like well we'll just clip
the last half-hour of episode 1 and make
that its own episode also there are
spoilers for episode 1 in here because
you know the end of episode 1 there even
videos like endings of that ending leads
into episode 2 so if you haven't seen
episode 1 of the mandalorian here we go
you probably should before you watch
this so the point of this episode is a
Mandalorian has gotten his mark it's a
little baby Yoda he was like well I
don't want to kill baby Yoda I don't
know the kid's name yet so we're all
just gonna call him baby Yoda or her I
don't know and Jawas have stripped his
ship of parts so he's like well I need
my parts back so jobless are like
alright can you go get this egg so I was
like alright I guess I gotta get the egg
so that's the thing Mandalorian has to
go get this egg of a creature bring it
back to the jobless jobless we'll give
him the parts for his ship if he does
and here we go which people have said
and it's totally true the Mandalorian
does come across it plays out like a
Star Wars video game he does missions he
gets armor upgrades video game that's
probably why I like it a bit I have good
memories of good Star Wars videogames
and when I don't get you a timely review
of Jedi fallen orders just because I'm
playing death stranding right now so
that'll take me nine years so that's
that but this episode does play out like
a video game as well not even counting
the fact that he decides to scale the
Jawa sandcrawler and I was like I've
played Super Star Wars this is gonna
suck for you and it plays out exactly
like I did and super Star Wars for me he
almost gets to the top he gets smacked
he falls down now he's back in square
one that's pretty much that level but as
the Mandalorian is playing out like a
video game this is that video game
segment that it's just it's the XP grind
it is like that MMO or delivery game
where it's like alright yeah you have
the package but you can't leave yet you
need to do this one other measure like
fine tack on a mission to this
measurement video game 101 funny thing
about baby Yoda did enter my mind in
episode 1 I was like what if this
doesn't take place after Return of the
Jedi it just says the Empire has fallen
what if it's like the SIF Empire and
this is Old Republic era and that's
actually little Yoda and Jedi are gonna
pick him up at the end of the show
however there are stormtroopers that you
see in the show are X stormtroopers and
that design of stormtrooper as I
understand
an emperor palpatine empire design odds
are Yoda just got busy in that outer
room Yoda having sex he doesn't have sex
it's a weird thought however Yoda and
Yodle around the council together things
happen then a printout of all the freak
nasty sexting those two did back and
forth hit the internet and that's the
real reason Yoda went into exile on
Dagobah and now we know you know cracks
me up in Star Wars is how easily people
forget about the Jedi and the Voorhis
Han Solo is like hokey religions and
ancient weapons that one commander
talking-to targeted Darth Vader your sad
devotion to that ancient religion it's
like all of this stuff existed and was
very prominent in the galaxy in their
lifetime how easily we forget it's like
anything mystical or force related
happens people are like what is that
what does that mean I don't know what
happened I I have no idea I can't
explain it it's not like for over a
thousand generations the Jedi Knights
for the guardians of peace and justice
is the Old Republic I don't know so this
episode entertained me just I am
concerned about the runtime 30 minutes
long you could have had this at the end
of the pilot episode and had one episode
that was about an hour and seven minutes
long or the rest of the episode is gonna
be a half an hour long I'd like a little
more because as I've seen from this
episode have hour-long episodes kind of
just feel like filler episodes and now
we got to think why are you drawing the
episodes out are you making your show
have more episodes than it actually
should have having eight episodes per
season is it better for you financially
than four episodes still entertained I
still like the character the Mandalorian
I'm still intrigued as to what's going
on which the intrigue is a big part of
Star Wars entertainment so I'm glad they
have that just in a show that's only
eight episodes long I don't feel like
there's time to have episodic episodes
filler episodes every episode should
probably push it forward a bit so as it
stands right now the Mandalorian Episode
two was a good first part of the second
episode of the Mandalorian and I guess
we'll see the second part of the second
episode called the third episode next
week all right so the Mandalorian
Episode two we will call it the XP grind
or the mission on the mission have you
seen it why did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you wanna see more
click right here to say more
[Music]